[Music]
this is star talk sports edition
and you knew we had to get here
eventually on this episode we're doing
the physics of billiards
yeah i said it billiards that's all the
pool i guess is also pool is that right
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah the
physics of that and you know there's
physics going on on that pool table
that's right and so we are long overdue
for handling this and i got with me my
my trusty co-host chuck nice jack hey
that's right and uh one of my favorite
subjects pool
i could have bought another house with
all the money i've lost
okay thank you
it comes out for the first time on start
talk there you go
chuck's chuck's debts in life
and of course gary o'reilly gary former
soccer pro yes i know okay
yeah
and gary i'm always impressed just with
your your genuine interest in all things
that are not soccer so i'm delighted we
have you as as my co-host thank you so
uh we got this in three segments one
we're going to talk about we titled
coriolis impact
coriolis
more about coriolis coming up and then
we're going to talk about trick shots
how could you not okay and another one
about the angles
it's all about the angles on the on the
billiard table the only time geometry is
super cool
yeah so when you're in school and you
say i never have to know this again yes
you will if you want to become a pool
shark yes right
buddy there you go there you go
that's how that works so
so before we introduce our pool expert
gary give me some background on this
sport
okay tiffany let's
let's do a brief history and i really
mean brief so back in the 1400s the
british and the french okay
[Laughter]
i thought all of billiards began with
the movie the color of money right yeah
right so minnesota
okay
yeah so here we go we we
way back so we start starts with the
british and the french aristocrats who
in the 1400s took lawn croquet
indoors because during the winter months
it was too cold and too wet however
the color of
the top is green to match the grass that
was broke eight was played on
right now the term pool is for pocket
billiards that came from america where
tables were introduced into horse track
betting rooms the betting there was
often done in betting pools so in the
mid to late eighteen hundreds to provide
them with something to do between races
now here we go fun fact now wait wait
because betting on races is not enough
ways to lose your money yes you gotta
add some between the races okay that's
crazy we've got to double down on the
pain so now now we're in the 1800s
1835 to be
specific coriolis wrote a book
on the physics of paul which i know
coriolis i know you do now coriolis go
way back don't don't
don't you bad-mouth this man
i think he's got an effect that you like
yeah so now let me see it's called the
coriolis effect wow look at that there
you go all right more on that more on
something
the book the book was published in
french
um but it wasn't translated into english
until 2005.
wow
there's a fun fact so we are now looking
at one of the classic
physicists mathematicians with an avid
interest such an interest in the sport
of billiards and paul that he went away
and wrote a book amazing
okay so that kind of gives it a little
more respect than
how it what it occasionally gets today
because when we think of pool halls we
think of shady characters yes you know
and
of smoke in the air and
somebody about to lose their money
somebody about to get beat up in the
back alley
and
uh and it hides cloaks the fact
that to be good at this sport you got to
know some science you got to know some
physics yeah and maybe even a little bit
of engineering and since none of the
three of us have this expertise
we combed the landscape
and we found the spirit of minnesota
facts
we found minnesota slim
yeah
we found
dr david
alexiator no
yeah i'll see a tour did i pronounce
your name right david
pretty close unless you want to be true
to my italian heritage and say al
chiatore that's it
okay but but i but i know what happened
you spent some time in texas and anal
pronounced nothing right in texas
so you're retired professor emeritus yes
recently recently yeah because you don't
look old enough to be like emeritus at
colorado state university you got your
phd in mechanical engineering at ut
austin wow and okay here it comes ready
dean
and co-founder
of are you seated
billiards university wow
there you go wow okay
i'm going to tell you something right
now dave
it sounds a little like trump university
we have a line of fine stakes we offer
as well
what happened when you were a kid and
you said mom and daddy i'm going to
start at billiards university i i don't
know how that would have played out back
back then but we'll get into that in a
minute so you've got books on on topics
as varied as mechanotronics i love that
mechatronics nail megatron excuse me
what was the program man
mechatronics what's that about this
sounds like robots that'll take over the
world
it's a
more traditional name is
electromechanical systems which is
basically uh you know emerge emerge of
mechanical and electrical engineering
with some with some computer science
thrown in right okay and another book
how to aim pool shots i love that and
you got your own youtube channel and
facebook page dedicated to pool and
billions this is wonderful to have you
on the show
i'm happy to be here thanks daniel
broadening our sense and understanding
of all the cool sports that engage
people so we have like a million
questions for you but let me just start
out any of us who've heard of coriolis
before whether or not we knew it was an
actual person we've heard of the
coriolis force which is actually in the
category of fictitious forces it's not
an actual force operating it's just
something that looks like a force when
you are observing it take place and so
you have a low pressure system let's say
in in in weather in the northern
hemisphere and if you have low pressure
that means it's higher pressure in its
surroundings and you have a cloud mining
its own business the high pressure
outside of it is going to push it
towards the low pressure in the inside
and so all the clouds are going to
migrate their way they want to migrate
towards the center
but
clouds coming from the south are coming
from an area of earth's surface that is
moving faster to the east
than the low pressure system it's headed
towards so it overtakes the low pressure
system
and clouds coming from the north
headed towards the low pressure system
are coming from parts of earth's surface
that are rotating slower
so they will undertake the system and so
all the clouds end up circulating
counterclockwise around that low
pressure spot and bada bing you get a
storm and all that happens in reverse in
the southern hemisphere coriolis gave us
an understanding of that and it's
beautiful and maybe you didn't know that
the equator moves faster than higher
latitudes all right because the earth
does one rotation in a day
and days what 24 hours and it's about 25
000 miles around so the equator is going
about a thousand miles an hour in new
york city we're going about 800 miles an
hour uh you go up to maine maybe 700 600
miles an hour you go up to santa claus
his sideways motion is very low
so all of this contributes to make this
this fascinating phenomenon and
i once tweeted and this is the last i'll
shut up after this
that there was a a field goal
kicked by the cincinnati bengals that
went 50 yards it was airborne for
several seconds and it hit the left
upright and careened in for the win in
overtime
and i quickly calculated that the
coriolis force deflected it about a
third of an inch to the right which
could have made the difference between
it bouncing off the upright coming
forward and
yes thank you it would have made that
sound too right and going in so in fact
coriolis force affects everything
whether or not you knew it and of course
the famous one about which way toilets
drain um but that's all bs for another
reason so let me shut up and hear and
hear our guest talk about this tell me
what tell me about coriolis and
billiards and and what's the weather in
a billiards hall
smokey and dangerous
what low pressure system is happening
cloudy with outbreaks of temper yeah all
right neil i'm glad i'm glad you
dispelled the toilet mess
yes yes because toilets toilets flush
the way they want to flush whether
they're in the northern hemisphere or
southern hemisphere exactly whichever
way the the species are pointing
there was a great simpsons episode that
featured that that that fact
yeah the simpsons has a lot of science
and math literacy in it we had someone
who studied the math and physics of the
simpsons on star talk a couple of years
ago so that became a whole episode for
us so so go on so what can you tell us
and also neil i'm surprised you didn't
mention galaxies dude
well yeah so galaxies all rotate um but
there's very little motion directly in
and out towards the center so they'll
spiral up on you
but
coriolis has less of effect and effect
going on in a galaxy just less so in
fact yes good
yeah so coriolis you know he wrote this
brilliant book in 1835 i didn't see it
until 2005 when the english version came
out and that was a year after i wrote my
book and i had done a ton of work and
when i saw coriolis's uh volume of
excellent work i was just crushed and
like my heart stopped oh you mean he he
scooped you
yeah by a couple hundred years wow
now wait did you reach the same
conclusions though without knowing his
work
well other people uh you know i'm not
the only one that's done billiard
physics other people have done stuff and
many people have come close to
duplicating much of coriolis work but
there's a couple things we might talk
about if we have time that that he did
and no one else quite did like he did
and in fact i honor one of his his uh
discoveries with the naming system i
call the coriolis aiming system so we
should talk about that at some point
okay let's do it go ahead
no no time like the present right
wait wait wait wait wait
i spent so much time explaining the
coriolis effect that i ate up a lot of
the time of this segment let me before
we before we we take a break because i
want to get to what you described could
you
let me know if in this first book that
you wrote mechatronics
could you
devise a mechanical system that could
play a perfect billiard game without
anyone's intervention
in the same way we can make machines
that solve rubik cubes and machines that
drive cars can you do one where it's
going to sink the ball every single time
uh yes people have done this now it's
not they're not good enough yet they're
not they're not they're far from a good
player right but there are many robots
that have been built that that can that
can uh use vision systems a camera to
see where the balls are position itself
it would know exactly where the ball is
right if you guys exactly
yes exactly so they they can see better
than we can see
but they can't stroke as well as we can
and they can't plan as well as we do
either right you might think the
planning piece i think can be there soon
but the work that's been done already in
that regard they the planning is not
quite there the shot making is not quite
there so just just to be clear when you
say the planning it means when i hit the
ball
where the balls end up after my
successful shot will matter for my next
shot bingo
that's what the game is the lead man
it's all about positioning you gotta
play the position game you gotta chuck
you gotta make that shot but you gotta
make the cue ball go to where a place
where the next shot's gonna be easy
right check chuck why are you this
fluent in this i thought you like i told
you man could have bought a house with
all the money i lost
it's a very expensive education
very expensive that's keys all right
well we come back
uh when we come back we're coming we'll
come back with one of the world's
experts on how billiards work on star
talk
we're back star talk sports edition all
about billiards the physics the billions
of course that's how we that's how we
roll on star talk i see what you did
there
that's how we roll
okay
we've got our we've got our our guest dr
david al
siatore alexia tour yeah i want to
pronounce it in its italian way and my
tongue is not letting me.
but so dave this is great that you've
done that you've devoted your career to
this uh even with active social media
presence um promoting it so let me hand
over to gary and chuck because i know
they've got a million questions for you
and we we have neil because it's it's so
interesting um the coriolis
sort of situation particularly with
parabolic cue ball parts um
it sounds as if i should not understand
it but i think i do but i need a really
good explanation from dr dave
okay here it comes you're ready yup
ready all right do it
okay so coriolis you know if you study
the motion of a ball
uh neil will appreciate this you have to
look at translation how the ball is
moving in a straight line or a curved
path and you have to look at rotation
how the ball is spinning and how that's
changing during the during the shot
all right so coriolis he did all the
math and he had to write what are called
differential equations to describe these
two effects
he solved these equations and he figured
out that
uh the direction of friction and when
the ball is sliding and skidding across
the cloth there's friction that's trying
to slow it down
down and change the spin
well he discovered that the direction of
the friction during a shot does not
change it's the same magnitude and same
direction during the entire shot no
matter how you hit it
if it's skidding and spinning it's going
to follow i mean the friction is going
to have going to be in the same
direction for the entire shot now once
he discovered that
uh because he was smarter than most of
us are now you know he had he was
creative in how he solved equations and
and he he realized at that point if the
friction is the same uh force and in the
same direction the whole time it's going
to be just like gravity
you like this kneel because gravity is
always straight down nice and when you
have projectiles projectiles the force
is always in the same direction the same
the same magnitude and that's why
projectile analogy follow a parabolic
wow so it's the horizontal version of
gravity gravity works
in our environment or here on earth i
like it i like it yeah that's really
cool man yeah so there's certain shots
where the supplies you know any time you
you hit the cue ball with top spin or
bottom spin by aiming high or low on the
ball right after it hits the object ball
the ball you're hitting the cue ball
starts sliding and then that spin takes
over it peels out and makes it curve
well as an example that that curve shape
is a parabola right that's one place
yeah another type of shot where where
the coriolis aiming system applies which
we're going to talk about is called
this sound like something the pentagon
was working on yeah we've got the
coriolis aiming system targeting
it's the only cue ball missile system in
the world
i actually i actually called it the bar
system first before i uh before i
decided to honor coriolis
okay b stands for ball a stands for
aiming point and r stands for resting
point we'll see where this comes in
later
all right so i must say shot and a lot
of turn a lot of terms in uh in pool
came from the french because as as gary
pointed out earlier you know pool
started with the aristocrats kratz in
france and uh in england
so a massey shot is a french term
uh where you actually strike down on the
ball from above maybe you've seen some
trick shot artists do this yes yes they
strike down the ball off center and you
know to one side and down into the table
it gives the cue ball a lot of spin it
gives it side spin and it gives it it
gives it what's called a barrel roll or
kind of a
like uh you imagine a kayak kind of
turning or or a spaceship spinning a
satellite spinning it gives it that
while it's going forward yes while it's
going forward corkscrew corkscrew spins
another name for it all right mm-hmm so
when you hit a massage shot it also
follows a parabolic path so anytime that
yeah i wish i could you know what i mean
by the way the uh the um
the what is what's it i'm gonna say shot
marseille
so i would call it the imma say shot and
and that's when somebody does it and and
they say i'mma say you owe me some money
i'm gonna say you owe me
another 50
and by the way that shot in a trick shot
is where you see guys there normally
there's an opponent's ball between your
ball
and on the target and the target ball
between the cue ball and the target ball
and so what you want to do is go around
their ball and that's what that shot
does it allows you to literally go
around the opponent's bar okay chuck
that's why we have dave on the show oh
i'm sorry
i'm talking about
dave tell us about that shot like
the ball around another ball
okay thank you okay so all right so now
now we now we know where we are
literally on
on the table if that
shot that masse shot is blocked because
of the cushions i have to go airball now
how on earth am i getting a stationary
ball airborne by hitting down on it
because i'll talk i'll talk about this
but we've got to go because he's
squirrel so we got to go okay sure
it's not as if i can bounce it yes yes
so there's that that's called the jump
shot
and i mean some some uh some novice
beginner players have probably executed
jump shots before but they haven't been
the legal type right the illegal type is
where you hit under the ball too low and
it scoops up in the air it's called the
scoop shot right that is not legal
all right for several reasons it can
damage the claws it's actually too easy
to do it it's very easy to do it if you
try
uh so at some point they wrote they
wrote rules to prevent that kind of shot
and to uh but still allow a jump shot
but now you have to hit down on the ball
and that causes the cue ball to actually
compress the claw and bounce off the
slate you know the bed of a pool table
is made out of [ __ ] slate geological
slate and slight's one of those
materials in nature that engineers have
not been able to beat there's several
materials like that in pool we should
talk about that too
so what is coriolis
all right so
you know so that's one thing coriolis uh
discovered that all paths on the on the
table are power parabolic just like the
the shape of a reflector and a headlight
uh neil you'll appreciate radar uh you
know radar dishes uh satellite you know
uh radio antennas you know radios
telescopes all these all these things
are parabolic shapes anyway i get i i
get uh distracted here right all right
so the other thing we get it dave dave
loves parabolas
all right so let's get back to the
second uh discovery that coriolis found
that i i was just blown away by
uh and that's this coriolis aiming
system
all right i call it the bar system first
let me tell you why so imagine a ball
you're hitting a mase shot so you're
hitting down on the ball so you're
aiming at a point on the ball that's the
b
bar method
uh if you project your queue the
direction of q is pointing onto the
table it's aiming at a point on the
cloth
all right that's a b a
all right now you have to so that's one
line we have a line that's that's
through the queue hitting the ball and
aiming at a point in the clause well
coriolis when he solved all the
equations for these mase shots
uh i don't know how he did it but he
found a way to simplify the math at the
end with some crazy geometry and he
found out that a straight line describes
the final answer even though the
equations do not look like a straight
line all right now the straight line he
found is from the resting point if you
imagine the resting point of the ball
that's the third point r so we have bar
ball ball point aim point resting point
all right so coriolis found
uh where the cue is pointing at the
cloth if you draw a line from the
resting point in the ball to this point
this aiming point on the cloth imagine
that line that line shows you the angle
the final angle that the cue ball will
head after it's done curving right whoa
so i call this the coriolis aiming
system because if you want to aim a
masse shot you know most people aim them
by feel but when i
i aim them i actually look at the final
line i want i kind of project that line
back to the cue ball with my cue stick i
add a little because it's not perfect
there's some there's some imperfections
on the pool table i had i'd shift the
line a little bit and now i know where
to aim my tip at the cloth through the
ball and i can make that ball curve and
follow that final pass
wow this is the coriolis aiming system
wow where where was this book when i was
losing all this
so
so dave we've got terms like english
squirt throw and one i could probably
understand swerve
um what do they mean what's it ever i
mean because english to me doesn't make
sense but it's very popular here in the
us yeah we say british aren't you
british scary [ __ ] you know what english
means yeah but not not not into terms of
billiards or pool there's no such term
in the uk well gary in in billiards
english is where you address the ball
and you go i sailed back
actually actually it is related it is
related to where how you address the
ball
where you address the ball with the tip
that's right
normally what chuck normally what
happens is you have one's butler
address the ball on your
sorry dave you were telling us how it
works can i can i talk now yeah
yeah
didn't you guys are
supposed to be the guest
you guys like my italian family if you
want to be heard you got to talk louder
you're getting with the program
okay when you hit the ball off center
you impart side spin clockwise or
counterclockwise spin
all right now just to be clear that's
clockwise from above seeing from above
yes so when you hit the left side of the
ball you are parting clockwise spin
yeah looking from above right
um so
you know in the early days uh gary
mentioned that pool originated from the
aristocrats that uh you know because the
weather was so bad in england they had
to put bring croquet inside they put it
on a table the balls kept rolling off so
they put these rails on the table uh now
when the balls got close to the rails
you know the croquet mallet it's like a
hammer right usually you hit it with the
with the hammer part the mallet part but
when the balls are close to these rails
they put on the tables they had to turn
it around and hit it with the end of the
mallet that's where the pull cue that's
where the pool cue came from
and for many hundreds of years that pool
cue was just a bare piece of wood just
like the end of a croquet mallet
all right now with a bare piece of wood
you cannot hit the ball off center very
much if you do it slips right off all
right
all right so in the early 1800s around
the same time of coriolis
um some some guy anecdotally decided uh
because their puke their pool cube kind
of cracked on the end they anecdotally
took a piece of leather from their shoe
and and kind of nailed it on to the end
of
the queue i'm not sure how they nailed
it but but they got a piece of leather
on the end of their tip and allowed them
to hit the ball off center now
you know it's anecdotal but this is kind
of true uh you know that's how that's
how the pool cue
evolved somebody put a piece of leather
on the end of the tip one day and now
they discovered they could hit the ball
off center and apply spin now i'm
answering gary's question where'd the
word english come from all right because
after these leather tips were kind of
invented around coriolis time
this english guy came to america and was
given these exhibitions
and he had this leather tip on there
nobody in america had that yet and this
english guy was hitting all these wicked
shots like mase shots and spinning the
heck out of the ball making the ball
dance around the table
well the americans hadn't seen that they
said look at this english guy hitting
these english shots england
and by the way the english is so
necessary when we talked earlier about
where you leave the ball
right at the after the shot after the
after the shot
not now something we have that's become
almost we've got to take a quick break
in a second but something we have that's
almost trope
is the person who just sits there
and puts the chalk on the tip of the
while they stare they're not saying
anything they're just putting the
charter you know you're gonna get ass
whooping right that's right
so when did chalk come into this i guess
chalk and slate go together as an as an
educator that was
that's what's in the front of a
classroom chalk and slate
yes
uh now the chalk it's not just the slate
is geological slate but the chalk is not
geological chalk it kind of looks and
feels like it but it's made differently
it's basically they get from the from
well i mentioned the leather tip and by
the way we still use leather you know
it's been it's been 200 years engineers
have not improved on leather it's just
really it's really good it's a dead
animal skin it's the best thing to put
in the end of a cube
so there's no vegetarian pool sharks
that's what that comes down to
yeah yeah i've had several people ask me
if there's a vegan alternative and i
there are some but it's not acceptable
yeah there's a vegan alternative it's
called losing
that's right but the chalk neil the
chalk is is to give the tip more
friction you know the leather grabs
fairly well but when you add this chalk
which has a bunch of abrasive particles
in it
so it's a chalk like substance that's
mixed in with some little abrasive
particles
it's kind of kind of like a fine
sandpaper but yeah but isn't it
different wait wait wait but don't
gymnast use chalk to reduce friction
that's different that's that's just to
absorb moisture like tell moisture from
there like powder oh from the palm of
their hand and bowlers use a rod and
they use a rosin bag same thing to to
take moisture off the hands oh my god
okay so let's take a quick break when we
come back uh i want to hear a little bit
more about trick shots and
also some of the culture of what it is
to be a billiards shark on star talk
sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition the
physics of billiards and we have one of
the world's experts on who thinks about
the physics of billiards it's dr david
alketore
i'll
i'll see a tour yes
you got to use your hands you got to use
your hands
i want to say it that way and i'm trying
to my body won't let me you should stop
today
just just call him dr dave dr dave
that's how what i'm going to do
dr dave um we all love trick shots do
they have any real role in competitive
billiards
yes there are what are called artistic
billiards competitions where the feature
is trick shots
yes okay
and so are they um i'm curious because
in the all-star break in basketball they
have the slam dunk competition in the
all-star break in baseball they have the
home run derby so these are the fun
things that can show up in a regular
game now they're all focused down into
one slot
into one offering so i guess what i'm
asking is
are there occasions where a completely
crazy trick shot
would be necessary in competitive play
yes in fact we talked about a mase shot
where you try to curb around an obstacle
that that is used and
that counts as a trick shot okay yes and
now in trick shots they do very dramatic
versions of that but you know in an
actual game if you have like you seem to
curve a little bit a few inches you can
do that pretty pretty reliably and a lot
of trick shots they involve a pre-set up
of what the balls look like on the table
um yeah so that makes it
is the art of the setup so that your
ball can do what it what it needs to and
the other trick shot is the jump shot
you know which we started talking about
before when we hit the ball on down at a
downward angle causing it to compress
the cloth bounce off this natural slate
and that's that's a legal jump shot i
didn't finish that thought earlier it's
a legal jump shot you can make the cue
ball bounce over over an entire obstacle
ball and this is a very uh important
weapon in modern pool so what are the
balls made of to enable them to do this
they're made out of a phenolic resin
it's a thermoset material that's called
but it's a phenolic it's called a
phenolic uh it's a resin resin yes wow i
know but dave
historically weren't they made of ivory
yes and i have to collectively apologize
for my entire sports history because we
we killed lots of elephants in the past
and and the real the real sad part of
the story is that uh you only got about
three balls out of one tusk
so can you imagine how many elephants
had to die to help the sport
yeah
but now we talked about the slate and
the leather tip that engineers haven't
been able to improve upon nature's
incredible evolutionary feats but the
the ball we we did find out better
alternative to ivory you know we have
about what about the queue i mean is it
are we are we stuck in historical
tradition and it's wood only or have we
have we made any advances there
well since the 1400s it's been a wood
cues just like that that original
croquet mallet and just in in recent
years in the last 10 10 10 or so years
have has carbon fiber carbon fiber come
out
and you know there's been other attempts
in the past with fiberglass and aluminum
but they just did not they did not sell
you know nobody nobody uh and you
couldn't play well with them but the
carbon fiber is truly a revolution it's
the first i think it's really the first
uh other than the ivory to phenolic
transition uh carbon fiber is the first
true revolution in pool equipment
otherwise nothing has changed nothing
has changed in hundreds of years yeah
but wait dave if you're trying to hit
the ball
some of what matters is the momentum
that the the cue stick has that you're
imparting on the ball and if you go to
carbon fiber which is obviously lighter
than wood
in order to get the same momentum i have
to push the stick harder into the ball
and maybe i don't want to do that maybe
i won't just want a heavier a heavier
bat as we'd say in baseball so what is
the carbon fiber doing for you
well the only thing that's made of
carbon fiber is the shaft
the front end of the cube right you know
most good cues are in two pieces
yeah i see when they walk in when a dude
walks in the pool hall with a suitcase
and opens a suitcase and and attaches
one piece to the other that's when it's
time to say okay you win i've
yeah these are people not using the not
using the the company
sticks on the thing right there getting
back to the momentum neil you're right
the the mass of the queue is important
and but we uh you know and good pool
players you know uh they want the mass
to be a certain value and within within
less you know a half of an ounce or so
and any good player can tell can tell if
that queue is heavier or lighter than
than their ideal weight we can tell
right by the way when you when you
purchase uh a stick like you just said
uh neil you can you can mix and match
the ounce for the back end so that you
can have almost a custom experience for
it for your particular queue
but it doesn't mean you ain't gonna lose
your money
still lose money
okay
yeah so neil you know when you buy
pulque a nice full queue it has called
weight bolts like chuck just says you
can you can take in or add or or add or
subtract these weight bolts from the
back from the butt end of the queue it's
called the butt yes all right and that
that's how you control the weight of the
entire queue and affect the momentum
that's transferred to the cue ball by
the way that's the other reason why i
love playing pool because you always get
to play with a butt
okay and you get the you get to hold the
butt the whole time too
[Laughter]
you're not helping
dave fits in here
does yes all right so
okay we
from our conversation so far as chuck
said it quite succinctly it's all about
the leave
but how many shots ahead is a high-end
paul billiards player actually mentally
calculated oh yeah that's like no no you
should know that we got to say that
differently how many are they capable of
knowing
given the chaos
and the randomness of what happens oh
man this is great go ahead dave yeah
great question great yeah
and by the way neil a good player does
not experience much much much chaos
the answer depends on the game on the
game you're playing partly so i don't
want to mention you know eight ball is
the most common game in america most
people know what that is you have to the
solids or the stripes first then pocket
the eight the other common goal is where
the accent is baby well wait it's the
only game ever where the black thing is
last rather than first off the table
you answer that yeah
very racist ball still controls
everything that's right
it's a very racist game very racist
games very rare okay so forgive me for
forgetting that fundamental fact okay
all right so the other game
wait so you could make inclusionist
games where you just invert it
where the eight ball is white and the
cue ball is black you could do that yes
you could
nothing you could just do do it anyway
right who's going to stop you it's just
one ball each right you just swap them
we could call that we could call that
woke eight ball
[Music]
all right so the other the other you
heard it here first uh
he's just
you've just written chuck's new act
oh that was good that was good oh thank
you so much
all right all right so the other game
nine ball that's the game of choice
in pro tournaments now and it's also
historically the gambling game that's
that's why chuck that's why chuck knows
this from his misspent youth
so a nine ball and neil i got to mention
this the number nine does that sound
significant at all the number nine nine
balls they're all spherical
uh uh no because they're eight planets
don't even go
just don't
no
just be glad you're in a zoom room right
now
up there
a ball set where each ball looks like
the planets you know different planets
yeah different planet but you ruined
that didn't you neil yeah
you just ruined that
so the thing is
you've you've probably seen them guys
just turn up grab a cue and they
intuitively
know what they're doing you kind of see
it with some other athletes but
what what are they calculating you know
what sort of geometry are they able to
see and feel just
without having a scientific education
well you say it looks intuitive but they
are thinking about a lot they just do it
very quickly now they're not thinking
about they're not and even i don't think
about physics and geometry when i'm at
the table except in certain shots i do
have systems
uh geometric systems for aiming types of
certain types of shots like bank shots
and kick shots where you're getting
balls off rails then the geometry can
help but you still have to adjust for
the real world physics on a pool table
you know the pure geometry does not work
by itself well anyway good players don't
think about any of that they just stay
in they uh they instinctively know how
to aim first of all
and but when they're when they're
planning they are doing a lot of
planning
and they always think at least three
balls ahead especially three shots ahead
yeah always okay now in a game like
eight ball
you often have to think through
everything if you're playing at a high
level you have to think about the whole
game and work backwards from the eight
ball you gotta first see where can the
eight ball go
what should i choose solids or stripes
well if the stripes are blocking the
eight ball then you probably have to
shoot stripes because otherwise eight
ball can't go in anywhere
so you always think backwards and then
and then you have to say well the eight
balls here these other balls are in the
way once i clear all my other balls
where do i have to get the cue ball to
make that eight ball right so you think
about what what is the what is the key
ball to help me get on the eight that's
the last ball you pocket the last stripe
or solid you pocket to get shape on the
eight that's the leave you talked about
before chuck the shape
and sometimes and sometimes what happens
is you don't have a shot to move forward
so what you want to do then is play some
defense to make sure that your leave
puts your opponent at a disadvantage so
that you're not leaving them with uh
three shots that they can then go ahead
and maybe go ahead and and sink the
eight ball chuck given your legendary
billiard debt why are we listening to
any
we're not just going to make this clear
i just want to be clear
do what i do not what i say i mean do
what i say not what i do
so dave what is it about a pool hall
that
makes steven seagal angry
what are you are you referring to
specific movie specific movie nails oh
no in five movie i swear in every movie
he's in a pool hall
and
and he and and he just
kicks everybody's ass with the pool cue
and the pool balls and and i'm just
wondering is there something in the air
that promotes
excess testosterone violence alcohol
fumes
[Laughter]
of all of the portrayals of billiards in
film and in and television is there one
that it was particularly moving to you
or interesting i remember there was
someone there's a twilight zone episode
on it had jack klugman i thought with
and yes and who else was if jack klugman
and uh winters i forget his first name
yeah jonathan winter was the one that
was so much you're exactly right yeah
and
that i thought that was poignant and of
course there's the
original paul newman yeah the original
the hustler followed by the color of
money
yeah thing about the interesting thing
about the hustler is that paul newman
starred in the original 1960 movie the
hustler which was brilliant had george c
scott yeah it had a couple of courses
yeah yeah big names yeah but he also
starred in the color of money which came
out in uh i think 1996 or something
wasn't that ostensibly a sequel and you
got to put someone from the original
just to give yes and he actually changed
just to bless the
the the cast yes so in the first movie
he was the he was the he was the shark
he was the shooter in the second movie
he was the mentor he switched he
switched roles but i think the color of
money was the you know is the one that
pool players see is the most important
because it really changed the industry
uh when that movie came out yeah when
that movie came out
higher class pool uh billiard
establishments appeared everywhere yeah
you know we don't and we weren't calling
them pool halls anymore because they
were nice places that had good food
beautiful tables
it's still that way it's still that way
yeah
that's true you can have part you have a
party a birthday party there at
a pool hall and what about the the the
scene which i happen to enjoy
and my cousin vinnie that was also it
was a pool hall scene there as well but
of course involved owing money and a
fight yeah and
so it's an interesting sort of pivot
point for storytelling and uh but very
fascinating how much a part of our
culture it is without us ever really
thinking deeply about that fact it's
there and we all know it and we all
enjoy it i think nobody doesn't like it
great game pool
and everybody everybody pretty much
knows what pool is even if they never
played and i often use pool examples in
my classrooms when i taught dynamics
classes to study a motion of machines
and by the way you mentioned coriolis
force before in machines you actually do
have coriolis force because we're
constraining the parts to move a certain
way while the while the boater plane or
car is turning we have pistons that are
going back and forth they're trying to
move straight so coriolis force is
required to to make that happen wow
so let me ask you about uh
we just have a couple more minutes chuck
okay very clear okay it's not a it's not
a trick shot but multiple bank shots
which are
to me one of the coolest things that you
can see very cool when you're playing
pool you know a bank shot is a bank shot
but like when you have a ball hidden and
you go two banks and then a third bank
off the rail and just kiss it and knock
the ball in that kind of stuff is like
so when you're picking your spots
how do you maintain the site for all
three spots because let me jump in here
and say i'm gonna jump in here and say
when you see the projected paths of
hurricanes and the farther along the
path of the hurricane the wider is the
uncertainty you know that's going on on
dave pool table so let me ask you dave
how big does your uncertainty get
uh even if you're highly talented at
this as it goes from one cushion to
another cushion and that third cushion
has got to have maximal uncertainty in
where you expected it to go
well there's actually systems for aiming
these types of shots and what you're
describing truck is called a kick shot
you know when you hit a when you hit an
object ball like a target ball and you
make it bounce off a rail that's called
a bank shot but when you hit when you
hit one or more rails first with the cue
ball that's called the kick shot so
there are there are several systems
they're called diamond systems you know
what they call diamond systems
no no because there's diamonds on the
table on the rails
that's what they're there for to help
help aim certain types of shots and
that's how that's what you focus on you
focus at where you're shooting relative
to the relative to the diamonds on the
first rail okay now these diamond
systems they were developed many years
ago hundreds of years ago and you know
when we had this other game called
billiards we talked about you know pool
is pocket billiards our tables have
pockets in them but the original
billiards was had no pockets
uh in fact i don't know if you know the
music the musical the music man you know
that yeah yeah yeah right here in river
city you got it right we got trouble we
got trouble you know what yeah
good job chuck i'm impressed i'm
impressed yeah yeah so the whole theme
of that musical was that this billiard
parlor which was a very gentlemanly game
because it was in the only there were
only three balls in the table no pockets
the goal is to hit the first ball
and before you hit and you had to hit
the first ball into the second ball
you're hitting a cue ball and there's
two other balls so hit the cue ball into
the first ball before the cue ball hits
the second ball you have to contact at
least three rails that's the whole
that's the game
that's billiards that's billiards
so those folks know their geometry real
well yes and they came up with these
systems to aim those types of shots now
the theme of this musical was that the
billiard parlor in town was about to
install an american pool table
right and that was going to corrupt the
youth of the town so they they needed
something to they needed something
wholesome they needed something
wholesome to replace that that
corruption and it was a marching band
and they needed 76 trombones yeah
exactly there you go
anyway i got what were you talking about
i forgot i don't know
i was talking about the diamond system
the diamond systems for aiming kick
shots well wait so wait it's a weight so
it tells me then that diamonds are a
start
in some version of a pool table you
could
completely calibrate all sides of the
table down to a millimeter why not yes
you could
yes yeah i don't need just one thing
that divides it into give me something
divides into a thousand parts oh i see
what you're saying yeah that would up
that would up my game but the precision
of my game and if you're teaching kids
math and they say in in middle school
i'll never need to know that for the
rest of my life yes you will
okay if you don't want to end up like
chuck you're losing all your money
the cautionary tale of chuck knights
well we only have uh you know we have we
have eight diamonds on on the length of
the pool table and there's four on this
on the side uh but pool players we we
can we can specify numbers in between
those diamonds so i'll say this is at
1.15 or you know this is that you know
it's between the first and second
diamond i'll say 1.7 you know you know
so we can we can fine-tune and people
can learn about fractions and decimals
that way too but anyway these systems
see uh here's a little cheat um that we
used to do guys in between the diamonds
see you play enough where you would pick
it out visually yeah but if you really
can't do that you go over you lick your
finger and you just wet the film right
there in between the diamond and then
that becomes your spot oh i don't want
your spit on the thing but use chalk
dude
damn yeah there's there's there's too
much on the line here to worry about my
spit well it's actually it's actually
illegal it's illegal to put uh no it's a
legal put a piece of chalk there too
neil you can't you know yeah of course
right that's the other thing people do
is they put the chalk block down right
where they want to yeah yeah you leave
stuff there even even you're still
burning cigarette in one spot as you go
around yeah i guess that could work as
well uh we got to actually land this
plane as we try to do
let me offer some final reflective
comments any astrophysicist
older than 50
never challenged them to pull
because if you're over that age you
would have visited telescopes in your
day after that it's remote observing
because everything is done
electronically now but at telescope
domes on cloudy nights every mountain
telescope has a pool table
and on cloudy nights you have to you
have to be on call in case the clouds
part everyone is playing pool we are all
badass well we're not world-class but
we're better than you you think we're
better than average and so this is an
alert
for all pool sharks out there watch out
for astrophysicists i thought you were
going to say never challenge an
astrophysicist at poole because they
will turn steven seagal on you and kill
him
and throw your body off the side of the
mountain and no one will never find you
neil how can we land the plane if we
haven't talked about squirt yet
okay so we've done english and it just
seems everybody hates english anyway but
squirt where are we going with squirt
what place does this hold on a pool
table
all right well when you hit a ball off
center
it uh it does not go straight
which is part of the challenge of using
side spin
it squirts off slightly sometimes it's
called we call it cue ball deflection
the cue ball does not go perfectly
straight where you're aiming it deflects
off to the side so we hit the wrong
right side of the ball to impart right
spin which is counterclockwise from
above the cue ball squirts to the left
slightly and you have to be able to
adjust your aim for this and that's
partly why these carbon fiber shafts
have been popular because as neal
pointed out the carbon fiber is very
strong and very light
and what determines the squirt is how
heavy the very end of the cue is
all right so and the reason is because
when the tip hits the ball
they're in contact for a very short time
and it's hard to believe but the tip is
in contact with the ball even though
it's leather which seems soft and
pliable it's only in contact for about a
thousandth of a second one thousandth of
a second
but during that one thousandth of a
second the the the the ball starts to
rotate when you hit it off center
when the ball starts to rotate the tip
is being pushed to the side by the ball
and the tip has momentum it has mass i
should say it has mass it doesn't like
being pushed to the side it pushes back
so when you hit the right side of the
ball the ball starts to rotate if the
rotating ball pushes the tip to the
right
it pushes back which makes the cue ball
go to the left slightly
this is newton's laws of action and
reaction bingo bingo okay oh cool so all
these things that are going on with
putin they have names yeah that's just
that's that's cool we have score of
course they swerve
we have squirt swerve and throw
i want to talk about throw briefly neil
because you like this i'm gonna give you
a little quiz do it quick you ready for
a quiz all right
so when you hit uh when you hit the cue
ball directly at an object ball let's
say it's a straight shot you're hitting
it perfectly straight if you have side
spin imagine this cue ball
spinning as it's hitting the ball what
do you think is going to happen to that
ball that you're hitting is it going to
go straight no no well it's gonna uh
you're gonna impart some of that
rotational
angular momentum to the ball you hit
that's true and that's called transverse
transferred spin and that affects some
shots like bank shots but that ball is
also not gonna go straight if you're
aiming perfectly straight if you have
side spin it gets thrown offline plus
the ball you're hitting is going to be
sent spinning in the opposite
rotates correct than the keyboard that
you hit which can affect go ahead right
right it's like two gears one turns one
way and one goal
and that's called transferred spin and
that will change the angle that comes
off the cushion if it hits a cushion
i think a lot of people would have spent
much more time paying attention in their
geometry class than in their physics
class had they known
about your pool tables i'm pretty sure
so tell us where do we find you online
uh we know you have what are we where do
we find you on facebook yeah people want
to see some videos uh that demonstrate a
lot of the stuff i have i have a
facebook page is dr dave billiards i
have a youtube channel dr dave billiards
i have a website uh dr daveblades.com
where i sell my book my videos t-shirts
all kinds of stuff cool i have another
website which is probably of the most
interest it's billiards.callowstate.edu
that's um all free stuff i have
thousands of videos
thousands of articles or hundreds of
articles i've written for a billion
magazines okay so that's your academic
uh pivot point for your whole for your
life
very good i have a lot of i have a lot
of physics and math analyses that prove
everything at the pool table so that's
might be of interest to you neil yes
definitely and to educators
yeah and educators because a big
challenge in modern times is how do you
make everything relevant and
i think no one will walk by a pool table
the same way again
maybe even steven seagal says wait what
let me calculate the angle on this guy's
knocking out your teeth
how about that guys
let's see let's see if i can make some
teeth squirt on
all right we're actually done here david
it's great to have you on and
i'm i'm always pleased to learn that
they're complete experts in things that
you know we don't otherwise think uh
would have experts or maybe would even
deserve experts and there you are
bringing the science down to earth and
that's what that's what we try to how we
try to roll here on star talk gary chuck
always good to have you
now now i understand chuck why you keep
asking for a raise yeah it's too easy to
get out of debt
we'll visit you in prison chuck all
right
all right guys i'm neil degrass tyson uh
signing off for star talk as always keep
looking
[Music]